و اتابع مشاهدينا في هذا الموضوع من
اسطنبول مع السيد طه عودته جل والمحلل
السياسي طاه مساء الخير اهلا بك مع نسيتها
بدايه اريد منك قراءه في توقيت هذا تقارب
بين البلدين
المشاهدين
او استلام الرئيس تركيا اوراق اعتماد
تقطيع العلاقات التركيه الاسرائيليه التي
شهدت هناك قبل نوعيه خلال الاشهر الاخيره
الماضيه تابعناها في مارس الماضي الزياره
مهمه قام بها الرئيس الاسرائيلي الى تركيا
الى اسرائيل كلها هي كانت هي محطات في
اطار السياسه التي تجدها تركيا خلال
الفتره الاخيره الماضيه وهي تصالح مع
الجميع وكانت النقطه الاساسيه هو اللافته
خاصه مع اسرائيل خاصه كيف ما تبعنا خلال
العقد الماضي هناك
الحرب والاوضاع في قطاع غزه ولكن خلال همم
بعد يعني تعيين السفراء همم قبل همم هناك
ايضا همم تبادل الت ما بين الرئيس اردوغان
وحكومه نتنياه والاتفاق سويها على العمل
سويا خلال المرحله المقبله انا بتصور
اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه وهي تاتي في اطار
الخطوات التركيه وهي كسب يعني مزيد من
الاصدقاء وتصفير المشاكل مع الدول كثير من
دول العالم طيب همم سيد طه برايك كيف يمكن
ان يؤثر هذا
او تاثير عوده العلاقات بين الجانبين بين
اسرائيل وتركيا تاثيره على المنطقه بشكل
عام
تاخذ هناك بعض الملفات المهمه وخاصه
متعلقه ان تحدثنا عن الطاقه والغاز نقطه
التي
كانت هناك صراع كبير في المتوسط في عام
2020 وايضا حاليا حاليا
هي انتهت سياسه تصريحيه خلال العام وسط من
الانطلقت الباب نصر حاليا تطبع ماء
اسرائيل وتتحدث مع روسيا عن مركز الغاز في
اسطنبول وايضا وصول هناك الغاز همم
اسرائيلي الى اوروبا عبر الاراضي التركيه
يعني بمعنى اخر المصالح هي تتقدم دائما
وقسطا نحن
امام او ضحكه صعبه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
الجامعيه
لما بعد هذه الحرب من دعايات ممكن تكون
سياسيات اقتصاديه ونراها حاليا على ال ال
بشكل عام خاصه في متعلق في موضوع تضخم
ارتفاع الاسعار وايضا بعض القضايا الاخرى
كالمواد الغذائيه التي تم حل نوعا ما في
ما يتعلق بازمه الحبوب على التصور اعتقد
يعني الخطوه الحاليه كانت تركيا واسرائيل
هي هدف بالدرجه الاولى همم صفحه الماضي
فتح صفحه جديده عنوانها التعاون والعمل
همم خلال المرحله المقبله من اسطنبول
السيد طه عوده رجل والمحلل السياسي اشكرك
سيد طه على كل هذه التوضيحات